hello good morning good evening good
afternoon wherever you are on the world
and welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel live
um there's no one else with me at the
moment I'm completely on my own which is
a bit unusual
um but there's a few things that's
happened today that I really wanted to
talk to you guys about
um so we're gonna do that Matt's gonna
join us a bit later
um and Mike's gonna join us from
probably later uh so we're gonna have a
few people in but yeah we've got a few
things to talk about
[Music]
go to the comments guys tell me how
you're doing
um want to make this a little bit more
interactive I want to do sort of more
interactive videos with you guys in the
in the in the comments and stuff so
we're going to do that today but
before we get into what I really wanted
to talk about I wanted to talk a bit
about how I get the information I get
because
um a312 hey diddling
um
I do get a little bit of confusion
sometimes I do get people sort of
um making comments that you know are you
I've got
sources and you know and all this sort
of nonsense it's it's understandable
there's a lot of people on YouTube
pretending to have inside knowledge I
think when you get to a point where
you've um
just let you know we can hear you thank
you thanks Bob
um see Bob you can be as confusing as
you like tonight because we're going to
be more interactive so um get get stuck
in there the more confused in the
comment the better that's like a red
flag triple I suspect
um but but yeah there's a lot of people
on YouTube and still pretending to have
inside sources I think when you get an
element where you've got enough stuff
right
that you know you should get less of
those comments but you know Andrew hello
sir 4am
wow oh boy Paul Malone how you doing sir
so
if you are regular side tracking you
know that I basically looked at
seriously with getting a couple of
sources early on in sightrex history
um Bastille from Belgium good evening
um basically because I did a video that
was wrong
um a chap told me that it was wrong told
me why I sparked up a conversation it
turned out he actually worked at MGM
he was able to introduce me to several
other people I know I've got to a point
where I've got a WhatsApp group with
about nine people on I've got a couple
of people that email me regularly and we
have lots and lots of really good
um good chats
um so and I get to find out bits and
Bobs of what's going on
apple sauce
um Brown Source battle confuse the
Americans but that's my favorite
um
we all talk about the petition a little
bit later but yes please every other
signature helps on the petition because
we want Brad right involved in the new
Star game
so
um I've got to a point where
um a lot of these people started talking
to me because Amazon had come in and
took over MGM and they just weren't
happy I remember doing a live video
um basically when um it was about three
weeks four weeks after the sales final
and actually done and dusted and
um just every single person that was on
a short-term contract which is quite
common in in Hollywood we know this
because that's a lot of The Strokes are
about
um just got all their contracts canceled
so MGM has never actually had any
official sort of like um they've not
sacked anyone and Amazon have been quite
proud of that that when we bought MGM we
didn't sack anyone but they kind of did
because they let loads of people go and
they just got rid of them on their
contracts hi Laura how you doing
um
so
I did a video about that and I actually
got I actually got quite upset because
these are people I'm talking to
but the flip side of that was a lot of
these people then got jobs at other
places the original person that I spoke
to got a job working with quite a major
talent agency which has just been a gold
mine for information coming through from
them so
but a lot of these people my point is
they're not high up Executives I'm not
talking to people like Michael Wright
head of MGM Plus or anything like that
I'm talking to people that are quite low
down in the pecking order so information
does get to them because then they're
asked to do things and the big piece of
information I want to talk to you about
in a minute which is really Stargate
related is one of the examples of that
it's information that's filtered down
it has been really interesting though
that in the last couple of months we
haven't really had much information
coming out about Stargate now I was
always told to expect that I was told
basically when they get to the point
that they've actually decided who's
going to be show running or director or
however they go about this
that The Whispers would stop
because the Whispers were happening
because they were talking to lots of
people MGM would talk well they were
taking in people and they're asking
companies to do pitches for example so
we know Bad Robot pitch we know penguin
and Parker picture we know the guys that
produce the boys pitched and we know a
couple of others
um but they're also talk directors
they're talking to a couple of actors
they did these sorts of things and those
things get out they'll be you know
somebody oh MGM would got in touch with
me last week and asked me about Stargate
that was weird so this stuff gets out
once they actually start making it's
toddler oath
um once they actually start making
decisions though they stop having those
conversations so they stop talking to
people so there's less Whispers
so that's why I've been quite interested
by the fact that not a lot has been
coming out
um the people I speak to said look we
keep getting stuff MGM are asking to
speak to people they won't tell us why
um and you know it's that's that's also
interesting but we are going to put a
little bit of two and two together there
but
I've had some information from one of
the people I speak to that's been giving
me good information actually because
um they are privy to what a lot of what
goes on instead of marketing and PR
meetings
and they've told me that at the end of
last week and only this week they were
basically given a directive to um
complete some reports now those reports
they want to know what
um we will think about certain scenarios
when this gets revived
the interesting thing really is great
from us
Austria to Australia hello Robert how
you doing the really interesting thing
though about these reports they are
asked is that they were specifically
asked to do
um I forget they were called it's
development data they've been asked to
do
so the person I speak to is we're asked
to do development data when a project is
in development
obviously
so she's saying that look they must have
somebody in place that's starting to do
the development work or now we hope
that's Mark Fergus with penguin and
Parker we think that's who they've been
talking to as we said those negotiations
going up till Christmas with Mark Fergus
the guys that did the expanse and his
company penguin and Parker but we think
those negotiations stopped at Christmas
a few arguments over budget and things
and he just wanted clarification from
the above what they're actually doing
but it could be somebody else we don't
know for sure because everything's gone
quiet but the fact that this is
development data they're asking for
is really interesting
so what development data are they asking
for now this is the bit that infuriates
me
because it seems to be they're still
arguing about what to actually do or we
can infer maybe what to do first so
they've been asked to do
um development data or a
basically a Fan's response so what they
think the what they think people will
actually respond to these scenarios a TV
series with original crew or at least
some original cast
David Tyler how are thanks for all you
do you are very welcome Sarah and
welcome I've not seen your name before
so very much welcome how are you doing
um and very thank you very much for the
contribution every little helps the
channel really really appreciate it sir
um
so um
I've lost my train of thought then thank
you David I really really appreciate
that but I've lost Patrol full
commitment oh yeah so a TV series with
or without the original cast so some or
at least some original cast members or a
completely new cast
the same they're asked to do movie data
so if they do a movie first with some
original cast members or without the
original cast and they were basically
asked to do a response to how they think
the fans might respond to those four
different scenarios
um
getting deeper but I have drawers up yes
you had sir
um you should always I could draw
so
those are four different scenarios which
I think are absolutely fascinating but
the main thing I'm thinking is
they didn't ask about a hard reboot
now I think that's telling in the fact
that they didn't because when we've done
these before and I've told you about
these sorts of requests for information
previously they have asked about what
would be the response to a hard reboot
and they haven't
so I'm taking that to mean that we're
not getting a hard reboot and this is
definitely going to be a continuation
something we've been told lots and lots
of time uh Mike from the solo one
podcast is going to be join us let's say
hello to Mike hello Mike how you doing
I'm fine thank you how are you I'm very
well sir let's flip to that review
because wow look where you are that's
all right yeah it's not it's not a
background it's not a green screen
luckily so the weather's pretty good
here so it's quite good actually real
um
just I'm trying to be very interactive
with the guys today so you're going to
excuse me if I flipping her out but um
Roberts could say like yeah they should
not repeat the mistake Star Trek Picard
so many old characters the new ones
killed off only one enjoyable part was
Atlantis what that they didn't do that
basically so um no hard reboot NoHo
reboot what do you think I don't know
how much of you you're quite caught of
that
um yeah I I did listen to what you were
saying I mean from what I gather and I
think that most people agree about this
that we really don't want a hard reboot
we do want a continuation of some sort
um I think that Picard is a good example
of the fact that a lot of people did
still have a big interest in a show
which is 35 years old
um I'm hoping that some of those aspects
which have obviously been successful
will be incorporated into whatever the
new Stargate project will be obviously
you don't know whether that's going to
happen or not but I mean do you agree
that that's perhaps more likely after
what's been happening or I mean you've
been hearing some stuff yeah I mean I've
been told for very long time that Amazon
I actually told that it was MGM were
reasonably open early on to a hard
reboot and we know that actually because
they thought about it in 2015. so they
they were open to the possibility it was
Amazon that said nah that'll piss
everybody off down for that yeah yeah
um so I mean that is the one thing that
I was always quite interested early on
before Amazon when the when the deal had
been when it was sold but it hadn't been
sort of finalized I was here in those
rooms then that Amazon were the ones
saying no hard reboot not hard reboot
you'll annoying everyone don't do it
yeah um so it's it's very interesting
other than that they're now thinking it
seems to be
there's still conversations about
whether it's a TV series or a movie
first
um Paul Malone you make Star get
exciting again thank you sir that's why
I'm I'm excited by it it's my favorite
show in the world so the fact that it
might come back is just amazing
um
it seems to be that they still haven't
quite
or it seems to me that this still opens
the conversation about TV series on the
movie and from what I hear that's down
to MGM MGM I think it should be a series
yeah or voices in MGM but I've actually
spoke to one person who said look it's
not quite as simple as MGM versus Amazon
there's voices in both camps if you know
what I mean but it's more MGM mgmp
because I think Michael Wright was a big
fan of Stargate and he really and he was
the one that tried to what Brad Wright's
Stargate on a series right he's like
it's this is perfect for MGM plus please
give me Stargate sort of thing whereas
Amazon are more we've got all this money
for a movie let's make a movie
so
um
I mean from my perspective and I have
said this before that if I had the
choice I would rather have a TV season
or series than a movie
um because you're going to get a lot
more out of it
um the example again is like um going
back to Picard where we finally got a 10
hour finale of that series rather than
perhaps originally there was going to be
one more movie after Nemesis which would
have been another just two hours
so we got a lot more but on the flip
side if it was a very very good
entertaining two-hour almost like a
pilot movie for whatever colors after
that it could still be good and of
course it would probably have a lot more
money thrown into it because it'll be a
I assume it'd be more of a TV movie than
a theatrical version I don't know which
one it would be cinematic really
cinematic so again
to get the attention going I mean how
about you add your own preference I mean
you've probably said this before but
which would you prefer I'd prefer a
series
um uh it's like we said earlier
um this is coming from Jennifer sulky
who's the head of prime and now MGM and
Studios
um Amazon have put a billion pounds or a
billion dollars aside every year for the
next five years to produce five to six
cinematic movies a year okay um and so
Jennifer Stark has sort of gone well one
of those should be the Stargate movies
that's why we're getting but it looks
like it'll be a cinematic movie which is
really exciting that was so here
exclusively first and now it sort of
seemed to be like the worst kept secret
in Hollywood yeah and that's the
deadline confirmed it whenever else
um so
I just I my worry was if they do a
cinematic movie and it bombs does that
kill Stargate
that's the fact it's a risk isn't it
it's a gamble uh and that's the factor
that you know is there enough of a fan
base and interest based on sg1 Atlantis
and the universe after all those series
um that there'll be enough attention
with seeing as some of the actual actors
coming back seeing how they've changed
how they've matured
um you know and uh
I don't know I mean Starkey was pretty
big you know I remember it competing
against shows like um Star Trek
Enterprise back in the 2000s where I
remember it was um one of these big
sci-fi magazines saying that you know
Sonia has got a really good competitor
now for being a very high sort of tier
and it was um sg1 about season six or
seven it was that was that point oh that
was it it is Peak really so it makes me
wonder you know I know a lot of people
out there who would love to see this but
it's again they're worried about the
general population of whether there's
enough people oh I remember that show
with that that show with the circle with
the water in the middle you know what I
mean it's the risk you know and so well
my Stargate has been around since 1994
in one form or another so it's a
long-term show
I don't think Amazon C is a risk Amazon
have been showing Stargate sg1 SGA and
SGU for years and platform they've got
data that tells them this is a popular
show and people still watch it over and
over again and it's about to switch on
they're about to get their own Freeview
channels
is getting like a best off Channel and
then the outer limits is getting its own
channel which is a series that's been
going on forever so yeah and then um
Stargate again a couple of channels so I
think that just shows and I'm really
hoping we're gonna get in this country
at the moment Stargate sg1 is on Sky one
and that's how I discovered it that is I
remember back in about when would it
have been they put it in about two
thousand that year 2000 and suddenly uh
I was watching Sky one for some reason
it was on the package was on my package
for a while yeah and I watched a few
episodes and I just fell in love with it
and it was and that's how I discovered
it
if you go on sky at the moment and go on
the catch up to see they've only got the
first four seasons of sg1 and that's it
and we'll add all of them
dwindling down and I'm wondering if it's
because the deal that they've got is
coming to an end so they had a deal with
MGM for Scott that's why
um it was on it wasn't on Amazon Prime
over here because I had it and that was
their deal sort of thing it was an
ambient Plus for a bit and then it
disappeared
um but the four the 4K HD version of sky
was only on I I asked you on it was only
on sky
but with this free view coming I'm
thinking a sky about to lose it and if
it's on free of you I'm a happy bunny
they haven't they're getting the HD
version as well and it's they've
re-edited it because you know normally
in a show you have that like well it
fades to Black where the advert's
supposed to go yeah they've cut all
those out oh okay one they go straight
through yeah so which I think is much
much better
um Robert made the point here no hard
reboot but like in Star Trek just drop a
few things that don't make sense now I
would think I think Star Trek went a bit
too far with that you know I'm a bit of
a
I'm a bit funny when it comes to Canon I
think there's certain things you
shouldn't touch
[Laughter]
even in the new episode it did might not
well I'd like to fix it we can we can
have five minutes talking about Star
Trek because we're starting to be doing
a live show talking about Star Trek
tonight that's right yeah yeah no it's
fine um but um yeah there's certain
things they shouldn't faff with and I
think there's certain the history and
stuff there's certain things you
shouldn't fast with and I definitely
think they shouldn't redesign things
like they said when they read down the
Klingon so they redesigned something
else I'm sorry I don't know why you're
doing that you're just doing that for
the fact of it sort of thing so if they
had the replicators in a new starter in
future and they come out and they were
robotic scorpions or something instead
I'm just like oh no
they could but do better CGI but they've
got to be how they were they were so
alien they're so iconic when we first
saw them in Nemesis all that time back
in see end of season three and I I I
remember when I first saw that
two-parter that's when I realized that
this was something big in science
fiction and that's when I really fell in
love with Stargate I think it was when
Nemesis came out in 2000 when it was
1999.
um yeah don't resign it please it's
gonna look how it was yeah I think so
Andrew makes the bargain Point here
there and I say that there's a risk of a
movie in that if it bombs
um it destroys it could destroy the
franchise I heard
um one person I was speaking to said
that the the plans seemed to be to have
quite a limited budget
right what he said it was a realistic
budget
okay which was music to my Instagram so
I think oh God don't spend 300 million
dollars on this movie because it won't
make the money back yeah but 80 90 100
million dollars and just get the money
back and then go straight to a series
I'd be happy with that but if the movie
does well
it's the best two-hour advert for
Stargate yes it's the best possible and
it's possible it could go that way it's
it's a risk it's a gamble you know I
mean we both have faith and it would do
well but it's been a long time since
it's actually been any form of it since
that um Catherine Origins weird kind of
thing which was with um Connor trinia
wasn't it I think it was and about what
was that about seven right years ago six
or seven years ago and that wasn't
profit that wasn't proper starter anyway
so
um it makes me a bit worried about it
but yeah helpful
um it's actually Stephanie's just asking
about Freeview it's actually called free
V so it's
f-r-e-e-v-e-e and it's a sub channel on
Prime where they show TV series movies
Etc but they put adverts in so it's got
adverts basically
um it's art stream part live so you can
but they have loads of channels they
have like a Sci-Fi channel which just
has loads of random sci-fi at the moment
on mine there's a um I think there's an
Andromeda channel oh okay um
and as things like that but I do know I
don't believe it's in Australia I think
it's only in America and basically
Western Europe at the moment okay I
might be wrong with that but um so we're
not sure we're with getting these
Stargate channels here but so far
whatever's had been on in America we've
had as well
and there are a bunch of channels on
Freeview at the moment that say to be
clarified or to be confirmed so there's
nothing on them something the blank
Channel season two so I'm like hey
that's the target Channel
um so yeah I am my understanding is
though that Amazon intend to make it
worldwide over the next couple of years
so you'll get it at sub Channel
um yeah it's in yeah northern Europe as
well but yeah
um
's got his patreon thing so yes we do
the patreon channel and after three
months you get a um a little sticker or
a mug or a T-shirt and stuff I'm curious
about that I like that you know you you
give to the channel and you really
support the channel which is amazing
people actually give me their money
which is just just might not I just I
don't understand it
um but it's amazing thank you so much um
but you get a little good stuff and I'm
really glad that they um that they
actually everyone said they're really
pretty cool
you know it's good that you get that
because you're recognition for what
you're giving us you're giving us
information you've got your sources and
we appreciate that so yeah
um my understanding is it's coming off
Pluto shortly that that was only a 12
months or I think it was a 12 month deal
and it's coming to an end so that I
think it's coming off Pluto shortly
um
but what would your preference be though
if you if that's right so I'm going to
promote you to head of Amazon movies for
two minutes
um you've got this option
it's happening Target's happening
Stargate Road broke up and a couple of
things they're happening I've got more
information about
um San Diego Comic-Con which we'll talk
about a bit later but um you've been
promoted you want to do a TV series or
do you wanna do a movie
I personally again it's not fair because
I'm a fan so I know about the past but I
would also look even if I wasn't a fan
at how the original SG-1 North Stargate
started which was a film with Kurt
Russell in 1994 which was good enough it
wasn't on that wasn't a mega Blockbuster
thing but it was it was big enough that
it was was it I don't know how much it
was it it was a massive hit it was its
tent it's mgm's 10th um highest grossing
movie of all time still okay I didn't
know that well okay
it only cost 15 million dollars to make
really yeah exactly right yeah so I
would hope that there'd be able to a
replication of that repetition of that
where
um if they did that so well in 1994 I
might be thinking it might be good to do
a movie route first
but
sg1 also had a huge TV franchise
so
I don't know again I would hope it would
be the TV option but that he or she
might be thinking it be um the movie
option you know as it did well the first
time and triggered all this stuff in the
90s yeah yeah I don't even think they're
thinking of it like that I'm thinking
they're literally thinking we've got the
budget to do it it's been agreed
and and I think they they I think Amazon
think like businesses right and um so I
think they've got the budget to do it
and then and then they're looking for so
instead of having a project that they
want to do and then they go find the
budget they've got a budget that they're
trying to then attach projects to
so Jennifer's outfit's sort of going uh
Stargate okay let's do it
they were planning the movie route why
not plan a movie with a bit less of a
budget and a bit of money carried over
for a potential
TV spin-off so they're kind of like
elements are both in that risk so a bit
less money and already having some money
ready for a TV version if the movie is
relatively successful does that mean
option
yeah I think so
um secular Monsters made the point here
that MGM uh sorry Marvel is decided not
to go to San Diego Comic-Con there's
been big news on that but I say we will
discuss that
um in a little while so hold on for that
there is San Diego Comic-Con
a couple of big rumors I've heard them
last literally the last two days
literally Monday everything changed so
um
let's have five minutes Star Trek before
I thank you and kick you out
okay well we and then we'll come back to
Stargate and we'll come back
so a big big thing about Warner Brothers
today as well um but anyway
the I I did a video last week I told
everybody I don't like the first episode
of Star Trek I found it very of Star
Trek Strange New World sorry I found it
very very disappointing I did a long
ranty video explaining why I found it so
disappointing
I've watched it again since thinking
maybe I was just over excited and it you
know and maybe I just need to give a
second chance no I still don't like it
um uh that that 20 minute fight scene in
the middle oh my God that drags even
longer when you watch it
um I I found out today though actually
that the guy that plays the doctor is
actually one of the highest
I heard about that yeah apparently
that's something which elbows can wear
until a few days before you've heard so
yeah yeah
um
I liked it I thought it was really good
I really enjoyed I have to say
um
isn't that interesting that you're so
wrong I'm so right but it's your channel
so I don't really have an opinion
I just found it quite entertaining I
just like the idea of them having the uh
Klingons everything having this trying
to do up a old Federation Starship and
trying to reignite the war although of
course the war was a joke in Discovery
we know that that was the problem so it
was a bad Link in that way I agree the
fight scene was ridiculous cut out 15
minutes it would have been fine
um and of course Pike wasn't even in it
apart from about five minutes in the
beginning but I just I just still found
it enjoyable yeah I just found it
maintaining
um you know it's one episode about ten
so you know it's early days but
um yeah it wasn't the most greatest
episode of track in the last 60 years or
of it but yeah I was entertained and I'd
just say bring it on for episode two so
interesting like saying they just seem
to be starting us on our web normally
the opening episode of a new season
I saw something did happen they are
setting up this suit because we know
there's but we don't know what it is but
there's something going on don't we
um
talking about the potential war and blah
blah blah so I mean
um yeah we'll have to see but I just
don't I don't maybe it's also the
captain bikes not in it but I think
Captain Pike's pretty much in all of the
next episode
I love the Trek quartz episodes that
we've had over the years
they normally work quite well as I know
you're away at your beautiful little
wood Beach Stone did you get to see the
secret Invasion episode today
no
give it a go actually okay it's booked
the trend of a few more recent Marvel
series and it's actually quite good
yeah
as well so yeah today but it's actually
I actually quite enjoyed it but what are
your hopes for the rest of the Star Trek
strange new worlds and are you hoping
it's gonna
um I I like a lot of elements of it I
like the fact that it's pretty
Standalone with a loose arcs going on in
the series
um I I don't have I don't know really I
mean
um I would hope that there'd be some
progress of the Gorn storyline and I
think the klingon's gonna come back
again
um
I I don't have huge expectations this is
one thing I think you said on another
show on another episode that you had
higher expectations for episode one and
you were a bit disappointed and I I've
kind of in recently my expectations are
a bit lower anyway than I watched stuff
because I hate being disappointed I just
thought we'll just go in with it and say
I hope it's gonna go all right but I
mean how about you what do you think is
going to happen in the rest of the
season do you have any expectations I'll
be shocked if I watch all of it at the
moment
yeah
honestly I'm I've always been a Trekkie
my whole life and I am right on the cusp
of walking away from Star Trek really
good season three was great the first
time I watched it and then I watched it
again and I didn't enjoy it so much okay
once you get past the Nostalgia and the
excitement you're always the interesting
actually when you start like watching it
a little calmer you're like this isn't
very good this is not very well written
and it it sort of wanders all over the
place a little bit and
um but the strike isn't as terrifying as
you think and I just didn't enjoy it
particularly I was like I got a bit
bored I started playing on my phone
in the background watching playing my
football game I'm like oh yeah
especially watching this most people do
that these days they don't sit there and
watch stuff they just literally like
they've got their life
goes out of the way I'm watching
somebody watch I watch it
um but um you know so yeah I thought it
was um style over substance and I kept
saying that about strange new worlds
it's style over substance it's
beautifully made
gorgeous to watch you mean would you
like that candy visual but I mean they
did the thing with the um Enterprise and
the first series spinning with Torpedoes
going around it and it was a very
populous scene so they obviously thought
well let's do that again and so the
inter pressure is spinning right now
it's just like oh God I've seen that
they did this last week they did this
last year I don't know what what they're
doing so I'm I'm just I just think
they've run out of ideas
they keep reading they keep redoing the
same stories
do you think there is no more stories to
be told with a series where it's had
like 800 900 episodes in about 10
incarnations could it run out
you're doing prequels
yeah but Discovery is terrible I mean
that's the secret that's the clear this
in the future and that's just a mess
that's oh that's a coolness so you go
into the future and you create new
stories
season three could do whatever it wanted
because there's no there's no they
haven't paint themselves into a corner
no um
a strange new worlds and we're going to
have Kirk back and you know the biggest
thing is that the Kirk they cast
the actor's terrible a million miles
wrong is awful awful yeah
um
he's terrible yeah well crap yeah what's
up to Hope I mean I'll still be watching
it it might also be that we've had new
Trek now for about uh when they come
back to 2017 or 18 and it might be that
the uh I think we have a really good
point here Star Trek season two is just
Nemesis Rewritten and he's bang gone it
was a mix between Wrath of Khan and Star
Trek Nemesis okay seriously all the bits
in it are like you start breaking you
start breaking the massive car down into
like it's based things like
um his ex-wife phones Kirk his ex-wife
or his it was his mama's child at least
phone Picard and then there's there is
at one point there's a calm moment in
pecan season three as well and uh
there's and then they have a battle in
it and then in a um
gas cloud sort of thing
um it's it's it's both of those films
mixed together
it's it's crap but anyway go on sorry
what are you saying sir no I was just
wondering I mean um do you think that if
and when Stargate comes back then going
back to that do you think that your
expectations will be very high are you
prepared for being disappointed if
that's the same case with that franchise
yeah it's going to be ridiculous
um there's almost no way they could make
this show that I won't complain about
something that's something why not I
mean you know in the end nothing's
perfect I'm gonna have to very much go
into it with an attitude of this isn't
um my youth you know because that's what
you think I think you watch some of
these things sometimes understands
you're like well my knees will start
working again I'm gonna feel 18 again
yay
um and it's not that's not reality is it
but
um I do I will have to go very much with
an attitude of realistic feet on the
ground the first episode's got like 15
years of time to fill up there's going
to be they're gonna have to tell a bit
of story here yes and just
um but at the same time because I'm so
excited because I love it I guarantee
you I will forgive an awful lot of crap
and I did when Star Trek returned to
Discovery the first season I forgave a
lot
the end of the first season before I
start
when I suddenly tweaked it was a load of
crap
um but I you know yeah I've forgive an
awful lot what do you think
well you have a similar sort of thing
and guys get into the comments what do
you think when the first series comes
out is there any chance it can be as
good as you want it to be I'd love to
know what you think guys in the comments
I
I remember when I first watched uh
Universe episode one and I I was a bit
thrown by that because it was so
different from the previous two
incarnations of Stargates and eventually
I got to light universe but I had to
adjust
and I wonder whether if we had a new
series you'd have to adjust again it
would be something where they they want
something to be different but in the
franchise and we as long-term fans might
have to have an adjustment period that's
the one thing I think is likely but
whether that's because of the way it
comes across whether it's the visual
aspects it's the characters I don't know
but I doubt if I've suddenly come into
it and think oh this is fantastic from
episode one I might be wrong but I don't
know it's different from Star Trek it's
different franchise they might do it
differently I don't know so
um I don't know I hope so but like I
said it's been a long time since it's
been on was it but it's 2011 I think it
was the last episode of the Universe I
think it was so yeah a long time it's a
long time so yeah
um yeah I just think that I think we
will have to forgive it a lot and how
many sci-fi series come that you know at
two seasons until they get really good
yeah but then you get like new doctor
then you've got two I've seen a lot of
what's coming up the new season he looks
absolutely Dreadful it looks absolutely
terrible so you know you can have a show
where it could it can go up and then it
can drop right down like a stone into
into some sort of void or something so
that's the thing things aren't
consistent in in long-term franchises
and you know as fans we will try to
stick with them
but you know there might be a point like
you're you might be thinking I've had
enough of a strange new worlds if Doctor
Who season 14 is the way I'm seeing it's
coming across so far I might turn my
back on that because it looks absolutely
bloody awful so far well they're going
to spend an awful lot of money on it
anyway so and to be honest doesn't
always work though money doesn't always
work though
first time I ever realized that money
doesn't work because I remember I that
this is a bit random but it does make
sense I promise you there was a Simpsons
Game a computer game when I was a kid it
was not like the N64 or whatever and I
loved it it was two-dimensional it
looked a bit like Mario and I loved the
game it was so cool but then they
released they did a re-release
um for a different platform about a year
later I was like brilliant different but
it was the same game pretty much but
they made
they need to try to make them look
three-dimensional and
and they ruined it really put all this
effort into like upgrade in this game
even though it's the same game because
it was a more powerful machine had come
out so they did the new version even
though
um but they spent loads of money on it
and they tried to upgrade the graphics
and it just looked crap because it
didn't look like The Simpsons anymore
so they made they spent too much money
and they ruined it
happens it happens yeah yeah exactly so
anyways Mike thank you so much for
joining I'm gonna move on I'll let you
finish off your show but thank you for
letting me join and um let's hope that
it all works out
fingers crossed
see you soon thank you see you next time
right so Warner Brothers now Warner
Brothers is a company that we hope might
get involved oh sorry I should say Mike
is from the solo one podcast I will drop
a link in the description to his YouTube
channel a little bit later but uh there
isn't one there
um but yeah great Channel he does loads
of little clips of um classic TV shows
and things as well as doing his weekly
podcast which is fantastic so anyway
Warner Brothers
there's a company I've been keeping an
eye on at the moment to see what they're
up to
um when David's aslaf came in he very
much planned for
um Warner Brothers to take advantage of
what it's good at it's got one of the
largest studios in the world it's got
Warner Brothers animation etc etc and
they actually realized they had more
capacity to make stuff than they were
for HBO or for the movies Etc they would
they were actually wasting a lot of
their Studio space
so he realized very early on right we're
going to start taking advantage of what
we're good at we're going to make stuff
they started making stuff for Apple they
started making stuff for
um uh everybody Amazon
Etc it was very interesting that we were
talking about the Lord of the Rings new
animated movie that is obviously being
done with Amazon and guess who's making
that Warner Brothers
um there's several other projects MGM
have had a couple of good Partnerships
with Warner Brothers to again like I
said to make the Creed movies recently
so
you know there's there's a good rule of
working relationship there at the moment
Warner Brothers have sort of reaffirmed
and underlined that statement by now
actually agreeing that they're going to
produce an existing show that was on HBO
and potentially a couple of shows that
were on HBO existing properties but
they're going to produce them for
Netflix now this is really a no-brainer
so I I spoke to
um to one of the people I speak to and
he said look this is a no-brainer for
Warner Brothers they have the capacity
to do it
they don't have the platform that
Netflix does but also it's like free
money you create a show if it's not
popular you don't really care because
you've already been paid
so
um you know that only there is the
contract's more complicated that's not
just like buying a product and you know
it being popular obviously one Brothers
get more money but there's much less
risk involved
so he said look that shows a willingness
from Warner Brothers to do this and
potentially to go into a deal with
Amazon
I was also wondering though whether
Amazon I think Amazon are looking for
more of an exclusive deal with somebody
to produce movies over the next 10 years
so I'm wondering if maybe that's not
necessarily A positive
but Matthew is with us he's going to
join us in a second as soon as he stops
vaping
I can see you sir
Matthew how are you doing sir how are
you how's life
I'm still muted I'm good how are you
everybody's with us
um yeah Laura Smith have you seen about
this submarine that's gone down let's go
to Titanic have you seen pictures of
that submarine
yep have you seen that it's controlled
by a Logitech
would you get a board that submarine
I wouldn't even buy one of them to play
like a crap game on my computer
they're terrible like the stick drift
like there's memes literally like you
buy a crap controller from CeX and you
get stick drift and now your submarine's
stuck in the bottom of the ocean yeah
it's insane
um so anyway I'll just talk about Warner
Brothers and Jenny's just this has made
the point it's actually I mean this was
on Deadline today as like shock news
nobody was kind of expecting this I'm
sort of like
I'm doing this for a while but the
difference is it's syndicating an
existing TV show that was on HBO Max and
is now going to be on Netflix and
they're opening up to do others do you
think that leans man more towards the
thinking that the Warner Brothers could
actually take on a big franchise like
um Stargate for Amazon or do you think
it's less likely because Amazon might
want more of an exclusive deal dick
Amazon could look at that and go well
look you're doing it for everybody
you know we we want more of an
exclusivity thing here
I don't know I mean have it if they
partner with Warner Brothers who already
do massive shows
it's like a safe bet
whereas if they go if if they went with
the likes of penguin in a Parker if they
went through down at the Sony route
yeah
it's a bit more of a risk so maybe
they're thinking of it like that I mean
Sony is a massive studio in itself
um yeah I've got a video that I've
recorded that will be out in a day or
two talking about the possibility maybe
animated movies that they could do
around Stargate franchise and things
like this as well
um which I I think is is the ideal way
of doing it if you're gonna if you're
gonna partner with a studio do it the
thing but to prepare Sony do animated
movies as well
[Music]
movie in the style of like Spider-Man uh
into the spider-verse
so it's it's kind it's not just like
your standard like Rick and Morty
cartoon it's like a proper Siege like
High budget cartoon kind I think I think
that could do quite well yeah
um which is the spider verse is kind of
trippy in like the effects that it uses
I imagine that with like ring
Transporters and like Asgard beams and
stuff like that it would be pretty cool
yeah I think it's a it's an important
I I think either of these Studios could
do star game Justice I remember Sony's
had a history of Stargate they've
actually produced a series of Stargate
already so
George Will McKay be married
and find somebody who's put up with him
that long actually wasn't he dating I
haven't watched it
was it was the thing at the end wasn't
he yeah in the alternate universe he and
Keller were together and then obviously
they changed the timeline
but who's to say that that still didn't
happen in this timeline
evely rocks animated in the future it's
the e e e e e
David Hewlett coming back and you'll
state yes please how happy would you be
I would be so happy if to your state
um it came back
she's lovely
I'd want I'd want five flights there
you watch Firefly today yeah literally
what's like three episodes of five
flights today should have been working
I didn't when I watched Firefly I
thought her character was really
annoying it was really annoying to me I
liked it towards the end but really
annoying towards the beginning that's
not Keller
um yeah
um
[Music]
so so tanisha's point out that yeah I
I've heard of a script for an animated
movie as well I think it would be
something though that would I think they
tried to do something to tie into the
new series so I doubt that would get
made
but
um the thing I was thinking that's
interesting there is that's actually the
story that then triggered giant freaking
robot two years later to say there was
an animated series coming
[Music]
loads of crap but I was actually like
about six months after I did that video
I said oh no it's load rubbish I
actually found out oh no it wasn't it
was just six months late they were just
really far behind
um but anyway so I I think it's just
interesting about Warner Brothers in
that
I think they'd have the capability to do
this and if they do seem to have the
willingness to make a deal whereas I'm
not sure Sony
traditionally and not as Keen to make a
deal
but I don't think Sony on the on the
flip side of that though I don't think
Sony or areas
successful at the moment so they might
have more capacity to do it
if that made sense so again but it's
willingness to make that they might be
looking for a big project
potentially yep I don't know I I
honestly don't know which one would be
the better
the better of the two because as you say
that both of them
could probably do a pretty good job
yeah
so honestly I I can't even I can't even
decide which one I would personally
prefer
I I to be honest it's the development
side of it I'm more interested in I
think that's more important
to be honest
we use the expanse example right so
where are you actually film it how
important is that compared to the work
the Penguin and Parker did
and writing the scripts developing it
um doing all that hard work what it's
going to look like so on and so on the
fact they did that show Bible I think
all that is is way more important
because then it honors everything that
came before it and it's
staying true to what it was before
that's definitely very important so it
is a long-standing relationship
within our relationship with MGM but
Warner Bros does a development
relationship
yep I think that's fair and also I think
the poll there is a significant politics
going on as well between MGM
because now I think there's there's a
bit of history between MGM and Warner
Brothers
that maybe not
um great I think there's a bit and
obviously you've also got there's a
little bit of MGM maybe I don't think
the people that work MGM now would
actually really care about this but
obviously Sony bought MGM Studios and
turned at Culver City I think that's
right
um and turn it into Sony Pictures you
just so if I was in MGM I don't I don't
think they're that petty the government
you bought a studio version well
um but they definitely wouldn't because
well they're gonna do oh you gave us
money yeah
um but the point though is though that
it's not MTM anymore anyway it's Amazon
yeah Amazon they're making the decisions
now so we've got to look at the
relationships that Amazon have with
companies I never had a major
restructure as well so it's like it's
not even the same people mostly yeah so
really what MGM wants in this scenario
is irrelevant yeah
um it's they're still having these
conversations and they're still you know
sort of getting their roaring sort of
thing but
it seems to me that it's it's what
happens the Amazon relationships are
important and Amazon actually has
relationships with two or three Studios
they have really good relationships with
Sony they have a decent they seem to do
a lot of projects with Amazon uh with
sorry with um Warner Brothers as well it
does seem to me though that Sony are
slightly notorious for being very hard
to deal with
and look at the whole Marvel thing over
Spider-Man yep they were have been an
absolute nightmare to deal with from
beginning to end it's for that you know
it's understandable with the sort of
Spider-Man thing though because he's
such a massive intellectual property
billions of dollars as well if in that
property away
I mean I know now they still got into
the spider-verse so that's that's their
thing obviously the Marvel side of it is
now completely different so they yeah
they worked out a deal which is great
yeah but they had to give up something
oh yeah
that's always like you you never want to
do that yeah if you own something as big
as Spider-Man you don't don't really
want to give any of it away
but I think I think
Best Best of Both Worlds now it's it's a
better scenario a better situation I
think everyone everyone's happy with it
maybe Sony are not as happy with it but
yeah whatever they've got other things
going on the the thing is it does seem
to be that there's a lot of internal
still internal arguments going on
between MGM and Amazon which just
fries my head
um I've I've spoken to Jenny a couple
times before and she said this is
basically the same thing that there's a
lot of infighting going on and not just
over Stargate over lots of different
things there's people I think at MGM
that genuinely feel are done to because
of what how Amazon dealt with the sale
Alex I was being told that people at MGM
were told that they were going to be
pretty much left alone to continue
acting as a studio and Amazon were just
going to be
um like a big brother paying the bills
was ordering ordering what they wanted
and
that very quickly as soon as they're
pretty much the week after the fair went
through they went
it was a rock pool it's what it was it
was a rug pull they they basically fed
them a load of lines made them think
everything was all hunky-dory
and then as soon as they got their foot
in the door pulled the rug on it and
everything
and unfortunately
that also meant that you know Brad right
script and all everything they were
already working on got pulled yeah now
we had to wait like what 18 months yeah
yeah exactly there's been massive
changes to Amazon as well and Amazon has
had to massively restructure like
everybody else they lost a buttload of
money when we all decided to go back to
work and stop ordering off Amazon every
day
they overstretched themselves and
massively during the pandemic and then
they all sort of went ah we thought that
was going to continue and we all went
well we're not going to buy off you
every day I bought so much craft off
Amazon they emailed me thinking I was a
business and I'm not joking
um are you a business would you like our
business contract I've got another
business
um no I'm just buying toilet roll every
day because no one in the shops has a
selling everyone
I just decided to take up every single
hobby that you can think of because I
was bored out of my mind I decided to
start playing Guitar again and played
guitar in years and I sold it the second
I went back to work and like I can't
play that stupid thing somebody get it
back I actually genuinely thought I was
going to start roller skating
don't I bought them locked down made
some crazy people and yeah yeah no crazy
people do crazy things
um
I have I started cooking and baking and
making bread like everyone else
all trying to think how to make toilet
paper because I could sell it to make a
fortune more health and safety guy
um we will have more helpful safety guy
but at the moment I am working on I'm
trying to figure out how to do it a
um a PR guy basically video oh yeah we
were gonna do the pr guys
we're going to do a HR video
I've done a PR video and the pr guy is
they've got a contract from the gun
because I'm going to do a series based
on like that it's about to get announced
the public and this PR Company is there
going how do we do this
and that's the video but I'm trying to
figure out what to do at the moment
um but yeah a lot of fun aliens do they
exist and in a picture of tilk indeed
yeah
um
that's what I'm saying only in my
opinion but it worries me that Warner
Brothers a serious MJ misuse and so does
Amazon creative SG could get lost in the
morass it it really could
um and
you know trying to change just had a hip
replaced and I'm thinking I think I'd be
next to you in the hospital but if I um
if I did that also I probably shouldn't
say that I'm sorry but probably a bit
personal
um but um
yeah I think I'd be in hospital bed
really quickly okay doing all the Disco
I I I put my back out building a
trampoline like three weeks ago
yeah I got off the truck I bounced on it
a little bit so that needs to test it
make sure it was safe for the kids
I was having a bit of fun as well I
bounced on it I only did a couple about
I'm gonna make sure I've tightened these
enough
I literally stepped off of it and like
hit my knee on the way down I'm like oh
I'm only 30 I'm younger than you but I'm
falling apart
[Laughter]
but yeah
um I think it's really interesting so
wga and that's the next bit I wanted to
talk about and I think actually Johnny's
just dumped a little information on that
as well it's basically decide if I've
confirmed a new contract but do BJ and
sag while close to a deal I put in
production on hold all over right so
we're going to talk about something
Comic Con in a sec because it's these
two things lead together
um very good friend of the channel has
told us that they think there's a
there's there's a deal there between the
wga so I asked a couple of other people
um uh the one person I speak to actually
works
um closely with quite a large talent
agency in in Hollywood and he basically
said something happened on Monday
um that they seem to think there was
there are either there was some sort of
breakthrough with the writer's Guild
anyway the writer's Guild he says they
shifted a bit of their bit what they
were talking about about two weeks about
a week and a half ago and they said they
stopped talking so much about Ai and
trying to do these sort of things and
they started talking way more about
money and this is because at the end of
the day the longer this goes on
there are actually writers and things
that are starting to feel the pinch now
financially you know they need a
solution so now they start to get into
more practical discussions
we've got the DGA the Director's Guild
um deal that's on the table
I'm basically being told there is
early conversations that they might the
WJ might accept a tuned up version of
that
um particularly that if they basically
say that AI cannot be hired as a person
which seems to me like a no-brainer like
yeah a computer can't be a person done
um so it would seem to me that
I think it's really interesting that we
we could be very close to a deal there
and if that can avoid sagafra from and
the Actors Guild from going on strike
then all of a sudden
the agents need to start working and I
was actually told that um the agents
basically didn't go home last night
by one of the people I speak to that
everybody was just the phones I'm
stopped ringing and they're working
their asses off on something so again we
don't necessarily know what's happened
he's not privy to that sort of thing
he's not an agent himself he's not that
but he's saying look all of a sudden on
Tuesday the phones just went and
everybody started working and
everybody's kind of spin their wheels
because nobody wants to book anything
because I think we book people in
and this is one of the reasons why San
Diego Comic-Con hasn't had a lot of
people booked in yet because if the
actors go on strike all of a sudden
these people can't won't go
um they could go to stuff you know
there's another issue though that a lot
of actors when I was talking to is
basically said
um
a lot of actors don't want to sign up
for things because they're standing in
solidarity with the with the writer's
Guild
so
you know sending a Comic Con because oh
can you come and do this and they're
going uh I don't really want to be
working I want to you know I want to
show that I'm actually supporting the
writer's Guild so a few actors have been
a bit hesitant solidarity yeah
but if they can get through and all of a
sudden they get a deal even if it's not
done by July even if it's not done it
would allow those actors to sort of say
well good we've got a deal I can go to
San Diego I can do this I can do that
and it seems to me that
the sudden increase in activity at least
makes this this company believe that
there might be a deal on the table
that's what is that that's what it
implies I think I think that's fair to
assume
um
so we'll have to see what happens with
that
um Dave's that's an interesting question
there if there is an agreement by the
end of July when is the earliest we
could see a movie or show
Jenny's probably the best person to
answer this question but it seems to me
on Alpha Ridge it takes about 18 months
for a movie
sometimes from filming to start so
really I think it would be two years for
a movie a series
12 months ish
um but remembering when the
this ends they still have to sort of do
the legal stuff and write contracts and
do all that stuff that takes forever as
well so yeah but I think a movie I think
would be two years
myself
it'd be interesting to see what if Jenny
has an opinion on that
um
yeah James saying I was scrambled like
mad once strike ended and got a ton of
talented on the San Diego Comic-Con with
a strike ended in March this is going to
be very very last minute
if this is done but I think those things
I think there's a lot of plans in place
people are still like I said all they've
had to do at a lot of these companies is
sit around making plans because I've got
nothing else to do
so they could have already tentatively
asked some of these people
would you do Comic-Con should you know
these strikes end yeah and then all it
is is a phone call
yeah after that of course not I'd love
to but can we just see what happens with
the writer's Guild can we just see what
happens with that
um can remember that um I don't know I
think I don't think the negotiations for
the actors ends that actually it's a
month isn't it negotiations I believe
and they start at the start of the month
the end of the end of the month and then
they vote whether to thing so I actually
wonder if the the studios and that are
giving them a bit more the right skill
bit more because they're they're looking
at the end of the month going for the
love of God we can't have the access go
on strike as well
um because then everybody's going to go
on strike
and then that's uh that's when this
becomes a disaster
yeah
so yeah everything shuts down at that
point everything yeah yeah I mean
they're even talking at the moment
um
yeah if they have a if they have a
script ready or producers of work in the
background then a series could be done
let's get started in six months of
filming at least is up to you I was
gonna say that I think it would probably
depend on how much work had been done
previously and if it was true that
Amazon put in a lot a lot more
um Manpower into producing these scripts
in preparation for this strike
then
maybe a lot of the leg work has been
done and then it's just it's just like
making the thing
yeah
I think so yeah
um we know they've done lots of work but
the problem was I think they were doing
a lot of work
towards a TV series
that seems to be what they were aiming
for until about March and Amazon was
sort of like let's see let's see let's
see and then it seems to be in about
March when
um Courtney Valentini was hired
around then and I and I know saying in
January
I'm being told they're delaying because
they are thinking about a movie and but
they can't do anything about that until
they've got a head of movies in place
and then they go ahead of movies in
place and then we're told she was given
a directive to start working on RoboCop
Stargate and um and to get the work for
Legally Blonde four which we keep three
sorry which we keep mocking is that
obviously the most we keep forgetting
about legally blind but it's the most
important part of the story
um so
um the directors have coming if they if
they had hired more more rights
beforehand we know there was been a lot
of work put into the into the TV series
well we we think it was a TV series
what if those extra writers were for
the movie side because there was always
that
um that thing of making a TV series and
the movie at the same time like in
parallel potentially yeah
so that would be something based on one
guy I spoke to that does work close and
he said that that seemed to be one idea
but he said it seems to be something
that a lot of production companies are
trying to do at the moment and is
literally trying to if you have the sets
are horrendously expensive the
um you know the ground rent in these
places are not just that on its own as
they're unexpressive so if you can have
more than one project using the same
space yep that saves a masses loads of
money so that's one of the ideas that
they sort of had this was you run these
things and that's what Marvel have been
doing for the last few years they've
been having lots of pro lots of projects
running side by side
and it's and Stan and Star Wars has done
the same
um and he said like it would not
surprise him at all if Amazon tried to
do that
um with Stargate
um and there was talk about a movie
followed immediately by a series so they
would be filming sort of like I don't
know if they've sung together or they'd
be like one straight after the other
sort of thing but but share and set
sharing background settings system CGI
CGI yeah CGI Sharon CGI would be massive
you know hugely if you have one company
set up doing CGI for lots of different
which is why Marvel
CGI is a very good at the moment because
they've got one team doing all these
different projects they've been sort of
had to slow down like the projects and
things but it is true that we believe
penguin and Parker were looking for
staff writers
um in January February sort of time
so that's that was that's interesting
but they are obviously doing
other things so it might not have been
Stargate but it could equally have been
just for God of War
yeah because that is their biggest
biggest project that we know they're
doing right now like for a fact because
it's been announced it's been green and
it's in production like we know they're
doing that so it could have been you've
been for that
but
they want they they want to Branch out
they want they want more projects so
yeah
my understanding was that they were
desperately trying to get God of War all
the scripts done before the right strike
and that's another reason why this sort
of that would make sense negotiation
stopped there's like let me just focus
on God of War and then we'll come back
to it yeah
um but my understanding is they don't
the God of War has done pretty much and
once the development work the scripts
are done I mean I know Mark Fergus and
Hawkins BR executive producers but a lot
of that what job's done really they'll
be thinking about season two
if there's gonna be one
um
but but yeah they'll probably get great
green lit for season two I reckon
it's a massive franchise
I I would be surprised if you didn't he
would have to bomb when it would really
have to bomb
um
the thing we're watching for though is
would Richard Dean Anderson is going to
Amanda Tapping Michael Shanks and all
these people gonna be appearing at San
Diego Comic-Con because at the moment
nothing's confirmed but they've done
every other big Comic-Con around the
world they did fedcon literally two
months ago a month ago in Germany I
can't see any reason why they wouldn't
do Comic-Con other than obviously if
they're on strike there's been two or
three in in England in the last six
months that they that one or both
appeared at
um I think Michael Shank a man's
dappings at one in London next week I
think in Hammersmith I think it is
something like that
um
you know it's just it's over and over
and you know it's more you know that
that and they've always been Comic Cons
they've always appeared at these things
but
it does seem to be that the interest has
just gone in the last 12 months
that they're just doing so many
that I think it's interesting but I'm
wondering whether you know know this
thing about what we should talk about at
the start
um
where we said like they're asking for
this information about
from like a marketing PR
team to something about right if we're
going to do a TV series with or without
Stars how would people react you could
do a movie with or without Stars how
would people react
um if you have Richard Dean Anderson Etc
of the Comic-Con
is that a good thing for the
announcement or is it potentially a bad
thing because that look I can't see them
announcing the movie
with Richard Dean Anderson Amanda
Tapping et cetera Etc unless they're
going to be in it
[Applause]
yeah I
it took me a good couple of things
seriously Frozen
um so I think we're still live so we'll
see when he comes back in a second
um
so actors can appear I wasn't really
saying that they couldn't I think I'm
thinking the more that they what I was
told was that they they didn't want to
because they felt it would be like
not following the no no I'm being
respectful to the writers
um that's what I was told to know
whether that's true or not
um
ah well the executive produced before so
if Richard Johnson generally did want to
Executive produce something then I would
get the same star in it we've lost
Matthew I'm sure we'll be back in a
minute yes we're still alive
um so
I wonder what you guys think about
we we came all the storyline a little
while ago that Richard's announcers
should come back to this and they should
kill him
they should kill Jack O'Neill and if
Matthew can still hear me he will be
spinning and shouting at the moment
because he hates this idea
but I would love to see
Richard Dean Anderson come back and it
acts as a bridge between the All-Star
getting the new have a movie that really
is focused far more around O'Neill
but maybe have him
dying at the end saving the world saving
whatever
um
I really wonder what you think about
he's back with us here he goes
hello Matthew
I want to say shut up Matthew I don't
mean it
you don't actually have to leave
now your Wi-Fi is screwed but
very slowly
no
you might need to restart there sir
um
give yourself a sexy videos okay Joe
Flanagan I'd love to Joe Flanagan he's
one of those he's a bit like Ben Browder
as well he hasn't aged too badly so I
mean um I meant to type in and Michael
Shanks haven't either to be fair
um but they could so easily do
um this let's see if he's
can you hear me now
we can hear you
you're lagging him back okay very cool
obviously I don't know what's going on
my computer if you just switched
it just turned off
I open my mouth and it just went off no
idea why
yeah I can't remember the question what
was the question
oh are you from a black hole
is he calling a black hole I probably
was caught in a black hole it's probably
just too hot in this room I don't know
anyway I think the question was
would it make sense for them to be on
stage if they're not going to be in the
show is that is that what you asked yeah
basically
I think
even if they're not in the show I think
it's good that they would be announcing
it because it's like them passing on the
torch it's like a visual blessing from
the originals
it's not just it's not just we're gonna
hire new actors and replace all of these
old ones it's literally them passing on
the torch and maybe they'll appear in
the pilot and do it like in the show as
well in Canon but I think yeah I think
that's
always a good thing when when when maybe
it's not it would be like something that
they've been told to do but it's still
full fans a way to be like okay
this is a transition period now we have
to get used to it kind of thing yeah
I've looked at Jenny's answer to this as
well at the moment but I I kind of know
a little bit
um so Joe Flanagan's knocked down for
any major projects at the moment I think
he's doing an indie movie towards the
end of this year
um but it's not a major thing Amanda
Tapping is executive producing a
um short series
um but that was supposed to end around
now I believe
um she was doing that other series
that's Fort Salem but then there was
something else she was doing so she was
executive producing
um I heard a rumor that they wanted to
get Amanda tap him back into this and
they were actually inquired about buying
her out of that contract so um but I
never heard any more about that
um
Michael Shanks is in one of those good
doctors or something but it was a guest
star appearance I don't think that he's
continuing that after this season he's
in the good doctor a good doctor or one
of those Stuff shows one of those
medical shows I don't watch
okay it's either the good doctor or one
of those shows I'll quickly Google that
because I like the good doctor yeah it's
either good doctor or like Chicago Hope
or something like that's one of those
shows I don't watch anyway
um I just remember seeing saving hope
it's Saving Hope Saving Hope there you
go well that ended in 2017 so it's
definitely not that he was nice because
he's um in Twitter and stuff I've seen
him on Twitter in a doctor's uniform
recently
because I've looked at all this not long
ago when I did a video for it about it
uh Michael Shanks oh no yeah he isn't
the good doctor
oh no in 2017 as well um it's only been
like one episode but I I think it's more
than that though he's doing a couple of
episodes I think and then he has got a
couple of projects coming up never
forgetting time cut
um I don't know if they're movies or
one's a movie I watch He's already done
it's impossible once a short so and
one's a short that he's in production at
the moment so he's not busy Michael
chance to come back we heard rumors
potentially that Michael Shanks was
already being asked about directing
and that was a while ago now though
um so so yeah most of the actors would
be available Carlisle would I reckon
would probably come back well he said in
an interview he'd come back in a
heartbeat David blue said he would come
back
um and essentially David blue said
everyone from
Stargate the castle Stargate
universities want to come back
um
it's available and sg1 and SGA but then
he said from SGA for the most part so
there's probably some people from there
that won't come back it meant was Jason
Momoa Jason Momo almost certainly
wouldn't come back yeah I'd love to see
him come back just come in for a day and
do one video but I'd love to see if they
did if Star first Stargate movie was
really popular
getting back to do a Dax movie because
that would be insane
um I'd land I'd love to be so easy to do
all right Ron and Dex movie yeah next
movie so I said Daxton
the Roman movie
um so that's a TV series I loved one
that's good anyway
um
well you're not getting him back
um pretty much everybody else would be
reasonably
all right with it
um
yeah I I think it would be interesting
to get a few of these actors back I
think I'm not sure about the Robert
Carlisle thing in that other than he
seemed to have been approached
but it was very early on when Fergus was
sort of it seemed to be he was bouncing
a few ideas around I wonder whether they
were genuinely thinking about doing
something SGU
and they're reasonably confidently get
David blue they weren't sure if they
could get Robert Carlisle so maybe they
just sort of approached him to C because
he's the one they weren't sure whether
they could get or not
but they were pretty confident to get
everybody else so that might be where
that was Jennifer said Carlo was not up
for it until after covid when he had
time to reflect so maybe he is now
yeah so I've heard this about a year ago
well I was just for Christmas I heard
that rumor that somebody said to me that
he was he was approached and I actually
I would say I'm like 95 certain that's
true a year ago he would have still been
doing something with uh for one two
because that's only just come out so a
year ago maybe that was true but what's
he doing now
he's just doing press releases for
maybe but um but I think they'd feel you
know I think they could they could make
room for that
um
yeah we'll get my mother to make her
feel more profitable for mainstream
viewers yeah all day if you could if you
could get Jason Momoa to do a Stargate
movie and that was the movie that they
came back with it would be an amazing
way to kick start the franchise because
you just have him all over the poster
um
we have talked about this before though
and you know
there's a lot of
psychologist or not we don't know
we don't know we hope not uh
honestly we have no idea the like say
the rumors is that if nothing changes
with a wga
I would say it's you wouldn't get even
money on
they're gonna strike
um if they can get a wga deal
and the DGA then ratify their deal
and
I think the actors would take a deal
it's roughly the same
um it would be tweaked but roughly the
same
um but it all depends on the WJ for me
if we can get a w2a deal by the end of
the month which basically means the next
week
yeah
um or at least in principle then that
could there's three weeks into a
Comic-Con they're going to need to
yeah realistically they think they're
going to need to get it done very very
soon for us to
see any kind of movement mm-hmm
yeah but um you know there's there's
also a lot of
it's not just about the strikes though
as well it's about all of these
streaming production companies everybody
saying we need to spend less money
um we've we've overspent
and we need to save money
um you know and that's everybody Disney
are losing money hand over fist Amazon
I've lost a crapload of money
um you know um there was big I mean this
goes
assessments that that Disney put into
that lost loads of money
um obviously then there was covid
everybody lost loads of money you know
so I mean it's just
it's just like the perfect storm and
it's just hitting us now but I I just I
can't get my head around that the
World during Cove it didn't know this
was going to happen
um you know everyone thought for a cost
of living crisis now
because of
because of covid well around the Ukraine
but yeah pretty much
well they they decided they decided to
pump the economy to to basically make us
stay afloat during during the time where
everyone was furloughed everyone was
getting free money essentially
that money had to come from somewhere so
then they ended up printing more money
which is increased inflation
it's a direct result of the actions they
took I understand why they did it in in
lockdowns and everything like that but
it's still
the knock-on effect it's having is now
for things like streaming services
people are not
subscribing I've cut down on my
streaming services I only have Netflix
and Disney plus now
uh-huh we've all had I I don't have any
any other form of uh entertainment I
don't I don't pay for TV I don't pay for
it's literally just Netflix Disney plus
and that's the only two shows that I'm
actually generally watching in a moment
manifest and Walking Dead
and and then
you're the only one still watching
manifest I feel like I'm the only one as
well
oh I did have a little um a little
Wi-Fi symbol pop up I'm on ethernet
though I don't know why the Wi-Fi symbol
pops up
say something
hello yeah they still is there's still a
delay going on but um the crackling is
not so bad
um
while AI is an issue for everyone and
string worlds is where
you at The crucial The crucial point now
is getting down to money
yes much better
um and royalties now an interesting
thing actually is that Netflix
they're going to change how they
um report their views
so they have been doing it based on
hours
watched basically and that's the only
way they did it and they said that this
this unfairly made shows that were
longer look like they were more popular
because a two-hour show gets 100 000
views it was getting 200 000 hours a
one-hour show gets 200 000 views it also
gets 200 you know it's twice as popular
in theory but it gets big so now they've
decided they are going to do it instead
they're going to report it and it's
going to be ours viewed divided by
episodes and sort of thing or duration
things duration which is more in line
with things like the Nielsen and how
they report things so
um so all of a sudden there we're going
to get a slightly more
um they're going to be reporting those
numbers in in a way that's more similar
to how everyone else reports numbers
and I think that's really interesting
because a big problem
um is that you know there's actually I
think Jenny's on board was starting on
talking about the Manifest mate I
watched the first two seasons do I need
to watch the rest
um so
um you did hear me say I watch manifest
yeah
um but I I I I'm not loving this season
yeah well there you go it's got me yeah
was it God
it's going to be God in it
um well one of the characters is
basically God at this point
three of the characters are basically
God at this point yeah yeah
um so
that is important with the Netflix story
though is because that has been a big
sticking point of this a lot of writers
are saying are we actually getting the
royalties we're supposed to be getting
because you're not very transparent with
the figures and the numbers you're
telling us what we've earned from a
project but we don't know that's true
because you don't you're not really very
honest about them
so them making announcements like this
now I think is maybe a little bit
telling and again I might be put two and
two together and making six here but I
just think the fact that they've done it
now when they haven't done it for the
last how long has Netflix existed is it
10 more than 10 years isn't it they've
just decided to do it now June
everything's going on
maybe that shows that they're trying to
you know
get a little bit more in line with
what's going on and
um
trying to stop the writers from getting
so upset maybe so that's important
that's I think that I think that could
be important but it was it was reported
on Deadline as just like uh yeah they're
just doing this I'm not I'm not even
thinking with the writing strike going
on that's interesting
well
so it's weird weird how how you say they
do their reporting for so two hours a
two-hour show gets 200 000 views that
works out to be four hundred thousand or
whatever you said
and then one hour show get 200 000 views
would actually work out less popular
like
surely they should do it like
I don't know kind of like how YouTube do
it watch hours
and then you have
they obviously don't make money per view
but they could calculate revenue from
so on on YouTube it's CPM so cost per
mil yeah so for every for every X views
let's say hmm
this is how much you get
like surely that's that should just be
the standard because every every
streaming that every
us as regular people when we stream when
we make money through a company like
Amazon uh yeah like twitch like YouTube
it's always CPM related so it's cost per
mil so cost per thousand views obviously
we're streaming you're gonna have much
bigger numbers so you can guarantee much
bigger numbers so they could probably do
a cost per ten thousand autographs per
100 000 or whatever and then just divide
it by that surely that just makes more
sense rather than
what you said
I I I say even the way I think so
because the problem also comes in
the people don't watch all of a TV show
in one sitting on streaming yeah
exactly but if you watch half the show
then turn it off and come back the next
night and watch it again that's two
views but you only get an hour or
something so it does it's in any comment
I think any way you do it it doesn't
really work but as like
calculated behind closed doors based on
those numbers it's all variables in the
equation but it's done behind closed
doors is the point and that's what it
seems a lot of varieties are very upset
about they're just being right you go to
work and your boss tells you next week
you're earning 200 pounds well done and
you're saying oh why so don't don't
worry and then next week you're only in
50 Quid this week I'm like well why and
it's like no don't worry about it and
they just they don't they won't give you
the important information on why your
money keeps going up and down sort of
thing and that's a massively over
simplistic way of looking at it I know
it sounds a lot like Carphone Warehouse
I used to work there and I don't work
there anymore so I can say their name
and shame them because I hate them yeah
well they don't exist anymore
um
it is true though that it does seem that
[Music]
um
that that they're like this and this at
the moment you know the production
companies and companies like Netflix Etc
and there seem to be a little bit of
move so but that's one is negotiation
isn't it the WJ are not going to get
everything they're asking for the
Studio's knocking and all the studios
are trying to do is save as much money
as they possibly can that's all they
want to do
they don't want writers to be on the
breadline I don't imagine I mean
you get some some boss up there with a
massive cigar going
if you put you know like a scrooge
moment like
um they're too poor they need to they do
well get them in they'll crack use them
lamb staffs they're the writers
Surplus population
um but um you know they I imagine they
want to pay people but what they don't
want to do they need to pay
the big draw actors loads and loads of
money because that's what they can
contract and everybody else gets what's
left
and it's a it's a small proportion that
everybody else gets you know like five
percent of the actors get a big chunk of
the money sortling
it's everybody else that's got the
problem
um these people are working for minimum
wage and things and having these crap
contracts and stuff they're they're the
people are talking about but the problem
is a small percentage for 95 of your
Workforce equates to a massive amount of
money at a time when they haven't got
any
at a time when they're all losing money
hand over fist
um so they're just trying to get as
they're just trying to get the best deal
they can because they can't afford
and no company ever wants to pay their
people more no company you know very
very rarely a company hey we're doing
well here's more money that companies
don't really do that do they but
um and the overall companies the overall
people that own these streaming services
they can pay more they just don't
because they put certain aside every
year Amazon are one of the richest
companies in the world you cannot tell
me that they cannot put an extra like
billion quid in a pot and be like pay
that to the writers and they wouldn't
even touch the like the side of the
bucket of their yeah
I watched a video on how much Jeffrey
Bezos personally owns if you if you
stacked off a penny yeah from there it
would reach the Sun and wrap around it
seven times
but he's got he's got to build those
penis Rockets
they're not cheap mate
penis shaped Rockets cost a fortune
well yeah but even then he's not putting
like he's not sticking his own money
he's got his money
that oh
but that's the thing isn't it rich
people all of the production companies
got a great look an Apple at the end of
the day they can afford to pay more and
um my son is pretty much they do they do
pay a premium because they're desperate
for talent to come across to them so
they pay a premium there's a reason why
Jason and and they basically go to big
stars like Jason Momoa and go what you
want to do and he says I want to do a TV
show where everyone's blind and I can
almost conceive the apples exactly sort
of going
really
what's that gonna work okay
I can see yeah and um and you know and
that turned out to be a great show
um but they can go to stars and say what
do you want to do
you know what you want to do and and
apple are willing to pay for it
um
yeah
it's like your point there says region
saying look yeah okay yeah they are
losing money
but at the end of the day they're not
losing that much money they can't afford
to pay more
so but I would look at a company like
Disney that's losing 500 million dollars
a quarter and saying look they they want
to save money where they can they're
sacking people all over parallel
with this report and saying they're
losing all this money
it's it's always like a division of the
overall company that's losing money like
the overall company isn't losing money
though that's like they can just
transfer it from somewhere else
a big company like Disney yeah they're
moving these they move money around yeah
yeah and they do that with Amazon
with apple let's just use apple as an
example if they're streaming platform
started losing a little bit of money
they could release a new iPhone get a
little adapter that costs 300 quid and
people will buy it there you go
yeah apple is the biggest community so
yeah
for Amazon can do that
Disney can do that Apple does that I
mean Apple basically their creative side
I I don't imagine that makes much money
if any
but it's a but they funnel money from
other places and they want to be a big
successful creative company so they're
spending the money Disney wanted Disney
plus to work so they're spending a
crapload of money and it's basically
been propped up by the sports side of
things and
um the parks but company like Paramount
can't do that
because they don't have they're not that
diverse like the companies aren't as
Diversified as that no no brothers this
is why Warner Brothers are now selling
shows to anybody that will buy it
because they know the biggest thing
they've got is they've got a massive set
you know they've got some of the biggest
sets in the world that's their
that's something they can really take
advantage of so that's them trying to
diversify sort of thing they're saying
like HBO isn't big enough it's not
making money
we need somebody else to help us and
they're again massively in debt
I honestly think companies like Amazon
and Apple
their streaming services probably will
never make that much money and I think
they know that but it's a vehicle for
getting you into their ecosystem
for their other services so obviously
Amazon is now a massive like
e-commerce Amazon web services
Amazon Alexa's Prime video Prime music
you've got all of this stuff which makes
them little bits of money here and there
yeah some of those Services I think will
probably be not on purpose but they will
lose money and they're okay with that
because it draws people into the other
services apple is probably a better
example of this because then you've got
like iCloud you've got Apple TV you've
got uh IMAX
iPhones iPads once you're in the Apple
ecosystem it's very hard to get out
yeah so having Apple TV doesn't have an
iPhone now that's why that's why the
with every iPhone you buy you always get
six months for Apple TV
because it gets you in the ecosystem
yeah got me chocolate got me yeah
um and Paramount is not in the best
um it's debt currently I think it was
last time I looked was about 15 billion
it owes
um they but that has been coming down I
think it topped out at about 22 billion
they owed at one point and but they have
been paying it off
um but the head of Paramount just said
look I think um David zaslap said
basically the same thing that 2023 is
going to see the height of streaming
expenditure from now on it will come
down
they cannot continue spending this money
um so yeah they're they're not in the
best shape and they recently got rated
as BBB plus I think by their creditors
which basically means it's like an ABC
sort of rating a a is the best rating so
there
um they got rated as okay
um and stable basically so their class
has been stable they believe they can
pay their debt
but that's about a b they've got a B
plus basically
which is a pass so it's a pass yeah it's
a pass
um but they they have and the promises
are we're now going to be going into a
period of debt is going to become more
expensive
so and that affects us and it affects
companies as well and when you owe
billions don't get me wrong they get
better deals than we get they're not
going to see all of a sudden it going up
to like eight nine ten
percentage of things doesn't work like
that one it's big businesses and that
much money but it still will be more
expensive to manage that debt over the
next few years
so
um
yeah I wonder if the Hulu being merged
news are true I have not seen any news
today but Hulu is is going to be part of
Disney
the thing is they're negotiating they
agreed a price for Hulu uh was it last
year a year before
I think
I think you've mentioned it last year
yeah so um was it last year God I tell
you what post covered everything months
and years and years and weeks and days
but anyway
um so they've got this agreement that
they've but I think it's 20 billion
Disney have to pay but now Disney go in
I'm not sure it's worth 20 billion and
now it was worth 20 billion last year
I'm not sure it's worth 20 billion this
year so they're sort of like trying to
negotiate and get a better deal
basically but um I remember you saying
that exact thing
well there you go so um but they were
looking like um trying to get out of it
at one point
they look like Disney were actually
trying to get out of it but they own
three quarters and I think it's
Universal on the other chunk I think
it's Universal
read so many of these things it gets me
so mixed up in my brain
eventually tried to get it out
um but yeah I think that's the
interesting stuff that's going on at the
moment
um I do think it's interesting that
we've got this little bit of information
because
I'd like to see this information about
these PR marketing I'm gonna have to say
like I've talked to Jenny about this
actually a couple weeks ago I get so
confused about the difference between
Public Relation team and a marketing
team because I thought they were pretty
much the same thing
and the more I talk to people about it
the more it seems actually marketing
people hate PR people and PR people hate
marketing people and I don't I'm like I
I I probably I'm probably with you there
I probably didn't I I don't know the
difference I when when someone says PR
cool that means they're going to be like
advertising [__] and so advertising
stuff I'm not an artist's Channel
anymore
nobody advertising stuff that's the main
thing
[Laughter]
um pop composers asked me though what's
the difference I'm still not sure I know
I don't know
Shelly is the best person to ask on a
basic level it seems like marketing
people are worried about selling a
project a product
so they're marketing literally marketing
how do we package this
so that somebody will buy it and public
relations people are more bothered about
what people are saying and stuff like
that so like they talk to like reporters
and stuff a lot more
I think that's right but Jenny will
probably correct us but PR is focused on
creating a positive image for the
company building a positive relationship
with the company's various stakeholders
whereas marketing focuses on focuses on
reaching customers and Prospects and
increasing sales for the company
so marketing is your advertising and
reaching the customers whereas PR is to
protect the stakeholders protect
everyone who's invested in it
yeah so I can understand then why when
they're talking about this do we do a
movie with or without the stars or do we
do a um oh Jenny agreement
oh no I'm slowing down
um or a movie with or without the stars
do we
oh that's mental it's like I'm an acid
my mind's really slow on your side yeah
oh crazy
um
rewind that and see what it says
um I can understand then why it would be
marketing and PR people that's what I
was told anyway that this was a joint
thing and it was PR and marketing people
because they're not just looking at
selling the Stargate they're looking at
the perception yeah and how would people
perceive what we're doing
um and and this this idea
um
I I just like the idea that she said
this was part of the development
so that means they're further along than
we think
if that's true
I would say if it's a movie they've got
to at least have a director
on board
that seems to be what they do first for
a big movie is get the director on board
um I mean I would even say that's that's
before writers
yeah
the most successful projects are the
ones that other brands work and those
different departments working together I
think as well
um yeah
um digital marketing Vision at Fox to
find Common Ground PR but we did due to
some
great leaders on both sides that's the
thing is that how often
obviously you've worked your whole life
which has been decades by the look of
you
um so definitely normal and um I know
I'd have that even I work for the
council I've always liked to work for
the military
the NHS or the council that's that's my
public service my whole working career
and I tell you that even in public
service where in theory we're all
pulling in the same direction different
departments fight each other constantly
yeah
um and it's it's like they're beyond the
function they're supposed to helping you
go oh these sucks trying to tell us what
to do yeah so that's the same with my
job I work in it
I work for a central team and we are all
just one team realistically but within
that team there's Finance there's HR
there's Estates there's
there's probably some other team who I
don't talk to because I'm not part of my
it team but
there are times when it feels like
we're we're battling against
HR or Finance or Estates
even though we're on the same team so I
fully get it fully good
it does happen and I say that it does
feel like these other teams are just
purposefully trying to make your life
hard and I'm certain that's what PR and
marketing people do because actually
Jenny thinks you're calling her old
[Music]
forever 12 and I'm with you on that one
then and I um isn't it awesome I once
had a psychological review done
for a job I wanted and um I got a
psychological review
um it's one of those jobs that I can't
tell you about it's that good how crazy
are you I'd say so it basically yeah it
was um whether I'd be willing to make
certain decisions but it was
psychological review and at the end of
it they give you a like a report and
obviously it was it's not pleasant
because it took about four days of like
testing to get the psychological report
and by the end of it it said the guy
said look
most people are in touch with their
inner child yours is in the driving seat
that's like
hello thank you very much yeah that's
probably me as well everything's a joke
that's great I'm I'm on board with that
brilliant
um but yeah I just I I just can't help
but wonder if we're getting into the
final stages now no and it's basically
only because I know this one person
and I should say that this person
actually isn't in marketing or PR
because of what they do they just find
out what goes on in these meetings a lot
um just to protect her a little bit so
anybody if Amazon's watching don't think
you're being clever you don't know who
it is
um but um
but it's really interesting that that we
wouldn't know this if it wasn't for that
person we wouldn't know this at all
um it's just lucky that I happen to know
this one person through Sheila
um and
you know I just think it makes it
interesting that other than that there's
no there's no news coming out since
um since the the deadline story yeah
you're mentioned it briefly earlier that
it's a bit strange that
over the last 12 months all these actors
have kind of
started appearing a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more all
these conventions
but I even said it in
uh we did that live last week
that it just feels a bit too convenient
that
David blue
Robert Carlisle
uh Brian
Smith now his name was um what did I say
his name's not John it's not Johnson
all three of them
pretty much at the same time
but it was Jacob
how yeah it was it was Jacob
um how annoyed would you be like you go
to an interview and you're trying to
sell your new show and John Smith
and um Brian Brian was there to
strategize his new show and they kept
asking him about Stargate and you know
um he said to talk about
um the full monty
and he just gets that's against Stargate
and it was that question that got
clipped and got shown everywhere and got
hundreds of thousands of views I'd if I
was Robert Kyle I'd be like I'm trying
to advertise them thinking full monty I
mean there's a massive post or something
so it is still advertising what they're
doing yeah
we because we all know is from those
interviews
um
I don't know I I should surely they're
just they look they're proud of the work
they've done in the past and they're
happy to talk about I know David blue is
very happy to talk about Stargate and
everything he does like even when even
when they wanted to talk about Star Trek
in that interview he wanted to talk
about Stargate
and he's a massive Trekkie
I I don't know
I don't know if you'd be annoyed I think
I think you'd just be like happy that
they're bringing up something
because obviously the fans want to know
and and they they want to
at least I don't know I can't speak for
actors I don't know how actors think but
if it was me I'd want to give the fans
what they want to know and if that's a
question that they're always asking kind
of thing
yeah if you're in a position at that
point to tell it to give you give them
an answer
which is why I think it's a bit
convenient that like because
whenever they do an interview they will
get given a set of questions you can ask
questions you can't ask generally
speaking there they're going to pack
before and don't they say what and they
obviously asked about Stargate they said
yes
which means they're happy for them to
start talking about it again so that one
report which I forget was called this
road for I can think what the company
was the production company was called
now but anyway um they asked the same
question to both actors exactly the same
question
the one who did Robert Carlisle and
Brian and and Brian yeah they asked
exactly the same question to both actors
which I thought was interesting it's
also interesting that this is a show
that ended 12 years ago 13 years ago
um about 12 years ago so um and people
still go on about it and they only did
two seasons and people still going about
it
um it was Doom I know but also I I
looked at a few
um sorry just to say I looked at a few
um conventions from a few years ago with
Richard Anderson Amanda Tapping they've
they've regularly done them and I tell
you what this the the place they were in
was half empty
look at the ones now they're from like
five six years ago when everyone's never
there crammed
that's gone one had loads of people yeah
it's it's I don't know if why that is
because
it's been shown on TV more in the last
few years streaming services have had
them so people there's a massive fan
base for Stargate in Europe and Defcon
was obviously in Central Europe it was
in Germany so yeah it's for for those
countries it's it's
quite an easy location for them to get
to I guess it's not as far as Comic-Con
and it's not in the UK
so it's yeah yeah I think it's just an
easier place for them to get to I think
that's why there's probably more people
because there is a massive European
audience
yeah
there's a really big one in France as
well which I always find weird because
they speak French it's huge in France
the one like the media is a big Stargate
Channel
um he used to say he's the biggest
target channel in Europe
well I've got I used to make
um
don't sue me out Amazon
MGM I used to make a Stargate game I
still got the source code for it but I
made a Stargate game I used to host it
and I met loads of people on online from
doing it and one of the people who I met
was this guy called Remy and he was
French
but you couldn't speak a word of English
but he loved Stargate and he learned how
to speak English
through Stargate now I select Chevron
was a word he learned first and most
people don't know what that means yeah I
just find it like crazy like we I was
like what 12 13 years old and he would
have been probably about the same age
around that point but he couldn't speak
a word of English
and now we have conversations in English
no
I just think it's
um so my last numbers were 300 000 fans
worldwide 1.5 to 3 million fans is
interested
I I think those that's conservative
but I think there are definitely more
more fan more at no because active fans
of people who are actively on social
media right now talking about it I think
that's probably a better number I think
though because of Stargate sg1 stuff
appearing I think streaming services
particularly in the last five seven
years that might be why that might be
why these things are happening now to
make people more active fans so they get
a more accurate representation
that's not enough to support a show you
need more than that active viewers and
but a new show would generate that
um and if it was a good show it would
generate that even quicker because it
would draw in lots of new active fans
but yeah
um I think yeah I think 300 active fans
the active fans and interest and
interesting fans that that kind of split
is fairly common even with
like YouTube channels like you have
YouTube channels who have watches thank
you so much sorry Manchester thank you
so much for joining us I know everybody
in the comments actually love seeing you
come on and answer questions and things
I really really appreciate it
um yeah so Jennifer actually used to
work on Stargate if you don't know
that's why people are going to nuts to
ask your questions thank you so much
General speak soon
sorry Michael yeah that that number 300K
active uh and then you've got 1.5 to 3
million interesting fans that's kind of
what happens on YouTube as well like the
300K would be the core audience
so people who are watching this stream
now there's 50 people in here now you
would be our core audience
there's 20 000 people that subscribe so
they've got a general interest inside
but you guys are the core audience
because you come and watch us every
every week yeah we're gonna record a
thousands that any video we put out we
always get about a thousand views yeah
so we've got a thousand people that
watch us regular yeah
yeah so I think that
yeah that's that's pretty normal I think
to have you've got people who are
interested and people who like the show
the people who are active and like
hardcore fans it's always a lot less
because not everyone's going to be a
hardcore fan of everything
yeah yeah
so we were asked a little yeah that's
that's true isn't it it's like football
and sports and all these things you've
got the people that actually go to the
away games and go to blah blah blah oh
you got people that sit on watch on the
Telly and they're interested but they're
not you know going to spend money on it
sort of thing and you've got you've got
and you've got layers below that as well
so it makes sense
um do you think reaction series help the
show yes
because
and it when it comes out I'll I'll jail
probably do a reaction I'll do a
reaction
um it'll be mostly mean
the reason I think it helps the show
though is because there's going to be
people who will wait for reviews
people who are going to wait for other
people's opinions if they then see a lot
of negative press about it they think I
won't bother but then but they'll wait
for those reviews and I think those
reviews are always important
for any show
you know there's a lot of people that it
does help and it gives it could also
kill a killer yeah gives people an
opportunity to talk about particularly
when there's YouTube as you trust you
you respect their opinion or whatever
which is why we try to be generally
quite level and balanced when I do
reviews and I talk about things I'll say
well I think
whether rather than tearing it apart
like somebody but
um oh yeah I wouldn't go into like the
cinematography or the
other you know pretentious like media
film and media courses that they do and
I think I liked it it made me laugh it
was good I just like to think of myself
as I'm not an expert in anything I'm a
Sci-Fi fan that will tell you my opinion
I'm not the brightest person in the room
I'm telling you that that off at least
half of the people not you Matt but at
least half of the people in the comments
are much brighter than I am
um and I actually think I talk to you I
talked to Harris sometimes and I think
Christ I'm thick I don't know I don't
know if if you're talking about Harris
is a walking encyclopedia a movie is a
freak yes
um me and him when when me and him do
live
we chat absolute
like okay
for two and a half hours we were we were
talking the other night and we were
talking about the flash because that's
what the topic of the thing was about
and for some reason we got into Ai and
we I literally had a massive like one
hour long conversation about Ai and like
how it's not even a massive issue right
now
um like if it's taking over the world
and all that kind of kind of stuff and
then we also talk about maths and
Science and like they told me yeah it
was it was I've got to watch the last
after the video I don't know because
apparently you started telling my
Stargate and what if two gates opened it
tried to talk to each other exactly the
same time What would happen and yes yeah
because he because he he
just said something weird on the Stream
he's like oh and oh there was two
Stargates in my head and I just thought
what if they got closer together and
then we added like half an hour of just
chatting like yeah
um
last night he tried to end the stream
after 30 minutes right I was like so I'm
like I'm doing a stormy
um a two and a half hours I said I've
got to go mate
sorry what we talked about a road trip
across Canada we talked about when I did
a road trip in um La a few years ago and
we talked about oh God it just went on
and on and on I talked about 20 minutes
about me um
driving an RV here nearly dying driving
up to the Grand Canyon it just went on
and on and on
um before we end our video because this
is the longest life I've done in ages
um but before we ended up San Diego
Comic-Con
for one we've got to remember actually
that I heard the rumor about San Diego
Comic-Con around March that that was a
potential
um
place that they were going to announce
it that was because that was actually
from a marketing meeting some some
people were saying can we announce it
now another one saying no we can't
actually don't know what we're doing yet
and they said right and San Diego
Comic-Con so we heard that rumor then
but it's actually deadline story
whereas where San Diego Comic-Con was
mentioned very recently is where they
were going to announce this and RoboCop
and Legally Blonde four three two one
Whatever It Is
um
that story came from Amazon
in that article I'm sure they did didn't
they sure that's right no I don't right
at the bottom of the article
if I remember right
you have a look anyway
um
excuse me if I'm wrong this in that case
it's just for me
um but I'm not the only person who's
been talking about it more recently is
the point anyway
um
doesn't mention it and um it shouldn't
say sdcc right at the bottom nope
oh it might have been another article in
I'll have to I'll have to dig it out and
I'll find it
um so
um
anyway the point is other people have
been talking about San Diego Comic-Con
um so
the interesting thing though I was going
to say was that that is the biggest
place for any company that they aim for
particularly if they're doing a Sci-Fi
project is they aim if that's that's the
big thing each year
um I actually wonder whether they might
do an announcement just before then to
drum up excitement
that they're developing
that they'll do beforehand if they do
will be something is coming and then and
then that'll drop the hype before the
announcement at Comic-Con yeah
but there's no way oh you know why I
read it now I I it wasn't it wasn't in
the deadline one of the I think it was
on the screen right when they announced
it they they think they mentioned San
Diego Comic-Con because that was that
was right that's right
um
but their argument was
that deadline of reporting this now a
few months before sending the Comic-Con
yeah because the decision's basically
been made in this kind of thing but um
what they announced at San Diego
Comic-Con is going to be if if anything
like we said we're in an unknown World
though anyway because the last time I
was told was about three weeks ago and
what I was told was the plan is still to
announce it Comic-Con but
and then there's a long list of books
put this bought that bought something
else but
um
but that was their understanding that
Sandy and Comic-Con is what they were
looking at and we have heard very strong
Rumors in the last couple of weeks that
actually Marvel apparently currently are
not planning to be at San Diego Comcast
yeah they pulled out didn't they yeah
but Amazon are apparently going in
organs blazing
but if you think about things like the
boys season four about to get
um shown and things like that
they've got the boys they've got
um uh we've talked about God of War
yeah they've got a few things we're
going to go in for
yeah
um and and the large like presence we've
been told it's going to be there
I I want it to be for Stargate and I I I
honestly think it probably is I think
that's probably going to play into it
like it will it will come into it
but looking at it from Playing devil's
advocate kind of thing
you could eat you could just as easily
say Well they're forgot of order for the
boys therefore
insert other Amazon shows that they have
here
yeah of course they've got several
um they've just announced they've
announced a bunch of things as well like
saying they've um announced that there's
going to be another Wheel of Time series
there's going to be you know a couple
other things so they could then be
talking about that I'm not going to want
to talk about all the time but
um there's a lot of things that they
could be talking about
um we hope that it's going to be
Stargate and we've heard a few rumors
that it could be but
I think that was I think the writer
strike has caused a few issues and
it may be the case that actually
negotiations with penguin and Parker
didn't restart
and they haven't
we know
that it's the deadline story is a
massive indicator that this is coming
yeah it's just when
um I I do not believe they will announce
RoboCop before they announce which we
are reasonably certain is definitely
coming I mean that's again one of the
you know the worst kept secrets in
Hollywood that they're re they're
basically going to do the original
RoboCop 2 script
based on the book sorry I think because
I think the first one's based on book he
then wrote a sequel
um they wanted to do the sequel movie
but because RoboCop was so popular The
Producers right now we want it done
quick so they did RoboCop too which I
actually still really enjoyed but was
not what they initially envisaged
they're going to do what they initially
envisaged for the sequel that that was
the plan that was the last thing I heard
was the plan
um so
yeah I think it's I think it's
I I'd give you two to one odds
on that we'll get an announcement we'll
get something solid at San Diego
Comic-Con or around it uh
asking where that where that
conversation was about the gates
um it was on Harris's Channel
if you join the Discord
when if I'm ever on or if Harris is ever
on I'll drop a um a link into the
Discord just so everyone there can go
and go and watch because it is is is
it's slightly different than what we do
here
it's more uh chaotic I would say
he starts with more of a plan than I do
yeah he then just he does and I feel so
bad every time I go on a massive tangent
yeah well that happens on this channel
as well so um but there is a link to um
oh GG slash so I'll just posted in the
thing
there's ever a link for a live stream it
will more than likely go in there oh I
shared on Facebook and our community
page as well yeah so it's there's a link
to directly to that video and I believe
it's the last half an hour or so isn't
you started talking about this
yeah half an hour 40 minutes something
like that right I've just saved the
links to the to this channel as well so
you can go into the comments you can go
to the description here and um there's
links to all the channels on there
all right man
two hours
I did say I'm gonna I need I need to
come off by nine and then it got to
about an hour and I thought oh we come
off soon and we're still here
we're done now though we are done so
guys thank you so so much for everyone
that's um getting into the comments
um again you've made it worth doing
um and and like I said we wouldn't do it
if it wasn't oh a little little bit a
little bit on whether it be San Diego
Comic-Con
don't even think about that yeah because
I know what you're like
now this is me that's saying this this
is me that's that's that's pushing this
that I I believe I'm confident in this
okay then tattoos if it doesn't happen
you get the tattoo
something else
and then if it isn't announced at San
Diego Comic-Con
just before it
oh God I'm gonna say if it's not
announced in July all right
so either just before or just after
Samuel conquer if this if we get to the
end of July and this has not been
announced
um I will give
um
I normally give 10 of the money from
charity to charity that we will generate
on this thing I will double that and
I'll give 20 percent
to a charity of your choice
right if it's not announced of whose
choice
you can choose me yeah okay then well
I'll get a million different answers
okay
I will give I will so it'll be 20 of of
the income that must we'll double that
what we normally give to charity we will
double
um if anybody would like to get into the
comments by the way and this month
and we're giving to a dwarfism charity
um and because my
um a close friend of the family's
daughter was born with dwarfism so um
she's got a really cool charity they
give lots of money to
um
helping these poor kids
just having as normal a life as possible
you know there's and they have a lot
it's not just some people are saying
well they're just little what's that
they're not just they have loads of
health problems
um she's a beautiful little girl life
expectancy for dwarfism is very low
it's much better than it used to be but
yeah it used to be like 30 and that was
it and the average person yeah but now
it's still really good so um so yeah
that's what the the money for this month
is going but guys if anything
um you have any Charities or whatever
that's close to your heart particularly
if you're a regular side tracker I'd
love to hear and
anything I can do to help I will help
the first time I did this I gave it to
Richard Dean Anderson's charity
just because I thought yeah
but I didn't I wasn't telling anybody
I've been doing this for about 18 months
but I didn't tell anyone because I
thought I would sound like a dick
um and um and it wasn't a lot of money
so but then I actually gave all of the
money from January
um to mind
um and then
um but then I just thought you know what
I'm not going to do that again I'm just
going to give I'm just going to continue
doing the 10. a month but that was me
the only reason I did it you know I did
it was they reckon you should have three
charities
and give like
um five percent of your income to those
charities
um and I thought that's I should be
doing that
um but I didn't want to do like it
regular so just each month I'd pick a
different thing
um
but yeah but I don't know why I'm
telling everyone now really it still
makes you sound like
but anyway
we're off so
um thank you so much everybody it's been
a real blast I love doing these lives
I'm going to start doing more lives
where I just come on myself and I just
talk to you guys as well I'm gonna stop
doing that a little bit more often it's
very stressful though actually because
if there's nobody in the comments you
just sit here going no nothing nothing
to say
but I'm going to do it a little bit you
should do it on your own all the time I
used to watch you when I was just a fan
I used to just watch you
and now you're committed I remember I
remember the live you did to apologize
and say you were wrong about Brad Wright
being at um yeah Amazon head office I
think that's like pretty much when I
decided to message you actually yeah I
wish that was such a dick thing that guy
he had to go at me because he said you
call me a liar so this if if guys if you
I'll tell this story then we're going
right so we've got two minutes I know
you've got to go
so this guy told me that there was a
load of meetings at MGM and Brad's
writes names all over them right and
this was when MGM
um still thought they were going to be
allowed to do Stargate the way they
wanted
and because Amazon hadn't told them that
actually we're going to absorb the
company you're not gonna be allowed to
do anything so MGM thought they were
going to get to make Brad's project so
he saw some meetings and Brad's Wright's
name was on these meetings he then saw a
big guy in a mask
come through and thought that's Brad so
he messaged me saying this guy's a
security guard
Brad's at the head office at MGM
so I did a video Brad said they had
office MGM there's meetings blah blah
blah and then Brad personally mentioned
me going no I'm not
sorry so I'm assuming what are you on
about and that's when he told me
guy in mask
so I'm like you prick
um but the meetings were about bad right
not with Brad Wright and we've realized
since that was when the decision was
made not to go with bad right script
um but we didn't know that at the time
um but I basically had to go live and
apologize I'm so sorry I made a mistake
and that but the guy that told me that
though then called me a liar and blocked
me and I'm like
you made me look like an idiot I'm not
calling you a liar but what you've told
me was wrong
so what was I supposed to do
um but yeah you stopped talking to me
after that
and now he's the guy who comes on and
leaves like crappy comments and changes
his YouTube channel every time
he's the Nemesis
it's possible
I do love that I've got a nemesis I
might I may have Nemesis I might have a
couple of people that don't like me
apparently there's a YouTube channel and
I can't figure out which YouTube channel
is but there's apparently this YouTube
channel out there that regularly calls
me a liar and um and and I but I don't
actually know who it is
I've never I've never found them but
it's been it's been anything I've said
it a couple of times people have said to
me
this is YouTube channel but nobody will
tell me who it is so if anybody knows
YouTube channel that slagged me off them
tell me because I'll go over and plug in
but um
it has been once or twice
yeah but they they have since apologized
so yeah they have apologizes
um no I I always get mixed because
they're both
Darwin apologize to me
dial the gate just had to go with me for
for being nasty to Jenny he refused to
report that was Karen
which one's the Skateworld
gateworld is Darren Darren apologized
David Reed is David was the one that
refused to get it yeah he's the one that
had a Goldust for what we said about
Jenny
no not we not we me
I know after and to anybody doesn't know
what the hell we're talking about now
we've got to be quick because I know you
gotta go but um we did a live and
basically Jenny went on dialogue and
Jenny spent the whole
thing going Side Track had it best when
they said this and Sidetrack dropped
this about Mark Ferguson I don't even
know how they knew this about Bad Robot
pitching him and the whole way through
subscription she said Sidetrack about 50
times
and I'm just like this is great and then
the guys refuse to say our name that all
the way through they're like and they
kept pulling once or twice you actually
seem genuinely sneaker when she
mentioned us again and then they asked a
question at the end well some of these
channels you know so aimed at us are
they just click baiting and Jenny's
answer was well sidetracked was a
clickbait because they did this thing
and I was like it's great and she said
look even if some of this stuff does
turns out not to be true it was true at
the time and I can and she backed up a
lot of what we said
um
which was great so um in that video then
we then talked about Jenny staff and I
said look I think she's been stalking me
she seems to know her bank account
details am I in a thigh measurement I
mean a leg measurement
That Was Then deemed to be a sexual
comment about Jen
um and I said I said I did say my inner
thigh mind and
measurements like we're talking about
subscriber counts I said she knew our
subscriber counts and then you went yeah
and it threw me off when she knew my
inner leg measurements apparently in
America that's
a really like like a sexualized comment
definitely a cultural I don't I did have
a dedication thing yeah I did have a
point of David I did say my inner leg
measurement not Jenny's in that leg
measurement which was really seeming to
be implying
um but yeah but Jenny did sort of
explain that she laughed it off
but she did explain that actually yeah
it did offend some people in America
because it actually is
quite a big
thing over there that's not a thing in
the UK so you know yeah it's just not a
thing here I just thought it's a
personal piece of information that
somebody shouldn't know I should have
gone with bank account details but you
know
yeah hindsight is uh perfect clarity
isn't it that we considered like America
to be such a similar Nation to us but
actually that's such a big difference
that we wouldn't that wouldn't be a
thing for a store you know I got it from
it was the fast show over here in the UK
you know like oh suit you sir and
there's always like or maybe like
friends when he's like he'd cook for
there's a thing about cooking the thing
and doing and and no Joe that's not okay
Joe I think that was one in my head but
um but apparently it's a thing but um
even when I tried to explain it to him
he wasn't having it no he's very close
friends for Jim so yeah
it's understandable really he's very
protective and he's a very close friend
and he didn't like it they've known each
other for like what 20 years so it's
understandable but yeah
um
your destination for gossip and
rehashing all these things
that's true yeah we've made a few errors
but um I said on Harris's stream uh
because we were talking about jokes and
about how how comedy is subjective and I
can make the dark jokes I can make a
joke joke about something in my life but
if someone made that to me it's a bit
different anyway I said there will come
a time at some point in my Sidetrack
career I'm going to make a joke and
that's going to get me canceled
it's just a joke just one day you'll be
gone yeah
at some point it's gonna happen because
I have like a proper dark sense of humor
yeah so do I I think again it's the jobs
we do you know it's like you work in the
NHS you joke about death all the time
because people keep dying so you joke
about it
um we will joke about this one he really
should be if he was a dog he'd be put
down it's like a quite a regular joke
for some people it's really not in taste
good taste at all but it's because it's
so stressful you've got to make light of
it or it'll just Crush you yeah
um and
um yeah so I was gonna I was gonna make
a joke when you were when you said who
you're gonna do the um give the money to
charity to
but I thought it was a very bad taste to
do it
I was gonna say every little helps
but I thought I'm not gonna say I'll say
it later when um
it's the cost of living charity cost of
living's gone
and I need more money
um but yeah
um hey it's
like so I I didn't get it that whole
thing with Jenna didn't get but um at
the end of the day I understand that the
website and a YouTube channel like
gateworld
keeps getting asked about this little
piddly YouTube channel called Sidetrack
that's coming up with all this
information and is it true and they
don't know because they haven't got the
sources I've got
um and they so they just assume it's
another YouTube channel making [__]
I can't I can't blame them for that
I don't blame even though I thought the
same thing to begin with so
we prove that right yeah until we were
the ones that I do get messages
occasionally having to go at me and I
just want to go list all the things I've
got right over the last two years and
stuff anyway thank you so much Matt I
really appreciate it buddy
two hours of your life you're never
getting back thank you so much I want to
go watch Walking Dead now so I'm gonna
go and watch wrestling so have a good
night and everybody in the audience
please thank you so so much we'll see
you soon bye-bye
[Music]